Hi, I'm Kanan.
I'm the strategist lead
for the AdMob in India.
And today we're
going to talk about
how can you build a successful
business out of ad development,
whether in India or abroad.
So let's first talk
about what is AdMob,
and how can it be useful to you.
So AdMob is Google's solution
for in-app advertising.
That means if you
have a mobile app
and you want to monetize it
through in-app advertising,
AdMob is a cool product to use.
So how can it work for you?
So think of it as from
a user perspective.
When you're browsing an
app, and you see an ad,
when do you tend to click on it?
Only when it's relevant, right?
So it's important from an
advertiser and a publisher
perspective to deliver ads that
are very relevant to a user.
So to give you an example, if
I'm browsing through a travel
application, and I want to book
tickets from Delhi to Bombay.
So I check the fares,
check the date,
timing, and then I decide
not to buy for some reason.
After that I move on to
a gaming application.
By browsing through
the gaming application,
if I see an ad from
the same travel app
talking about discounted
fares from Delhi to Bombay,
it might catch my eye.
That is something
I'm interested in,
that's something
that's relevant to me.
So, if I click on it, you,
as a publisher of the app,
will earn money from that click.
So it's important to deliver
ads that are very relevant.
And that is what
Google's technology does.
It ensures that only relevant
ads use the right users.
The other thing
that is important
is to check where are
your users coming from,
where are you getting the
clicks and the revenue from.
So we have advanced features,
reporting and filters,
which allow you to do just that.
The other thing that's
important is to maximize reach.
So If you build a
really cool app,
it's important to make sure
you reach the right users,
people can find your
app easily, especially
considering the kind of
competition that's out there.
So think of an app that
is really, really popular.
It became popular for a reason,
because the UX is really good,
people find it engaging.
So it's important to
build a quality app,
but it's also very
important that people
can find your application.
So discoverability, and
maximizing downloads,
maximizing revenue
is something else
that you need to keep in mind
when you're building an app
business, and this is something
that we hope to help you with.
The other interesting
thing about AdMob
is that not only
does it allow you
to monetize your
mobile applications,
but you can also
use it to promote
your apps as an advertiser.
That means if you
want to showcase
your app on other
people's applications,
you can use AdMob.
It's very simple to set up.
But let's focus on the
monetization side of it.
So if you are an app
developer and you
need to figure out how you're
going to make money out of it,
you need certain
monetization options.
So essentially
there are four ways
to monetize an application.
The first is a paid model.
So that means your app
is [INAUDIBLE] paid.
If a user wants to
download it and use it,
they have to first
make a payment
through the Play Store
or any other app store.
The second model is a freemium
model, which is more popular.
How the freemium model works
is if you have a mobile app,
like a game, which
has about 100 levels,
you make the first 10
levels completely free.
So, from a user perspective,
it is more effective
because I download
the application,
I test out the first ten apps.
If I think it's an engaging app
and I want to play the next 90
levels too, I make a payment
of, say, $1 or $0.50 or $2,
whatever you define, I
get access to the rest
of the levels.
So as a user, I'm
sort of getting
a sense of what the game is,
I know what I'm paying for,
so for me its value for
money, so it's easier for me
to make that payment.
The third model is
in-app purchases.
So you can combine this
with both the other options.
So in-app purchase is a
model where you buy something
within the app while
you're engaging with it.
If it's a game, you can
pay for a booster of sorts.
Or, if it's a
social app, you can
pay for an additional
feature which
may not be otherwise available.
The fourth and the most popular
model is in-app advertising.
That means it's a
completely free app,
and you monetize
it by placing ads
which are both relevant to
the user, and also engaging.
So this is where AdMob comes in.
It helps you monetize by
placing ads in your existing
application.
So advertising is an easy way
to offset development costs.
So if you already have
an app out in the market,
you're working on
the second one,
you need some sort
of revenue coming in.
So, because AdMob is
just plug and play,
it's very easy to
work around it.
And revenues scale as you grow.
Because, if you have
only 10 downloads,
your reach is
limited, but as you
go from 100 downloads
to 10,000 to a million,
your user base is growing
more and more people engaging
with the ads, and they tend
to click on more of such ads
and you get paid even more.
So revenues
definitely will scale
and you will make more and
more revenue as you grow.
And, because it's
such a simple product,
you can start earning
revenue right away.
So as soon as you create an
account and implement the SDK,
ads will start showing on
your mobile application.
So let's take a step
back and understand
how AdMob essentially works.
You create an account
in AdMob, which
is a few basic steps, like
your username, billing address.
And then specify the
kind of app that you've
built, whether it's an Android
app, or iOS, or Windows.
And after that it allows
you to download the SDK.
Once you integrate the SDK
in your mobile application,
ads will start
showing instantly.
From then on, how do you
start making revenue?
So your app is uploaded on
the Play Store, for instance.
I as a user browse through it.
I think it's interesting,
I download it.
After downloading, I will
launch the application,
and, once I'm
engaging with it, I'll
start seeing ads at
the bottom or top,
or wherever you
choose to place them.
If I think it's interesting
or if it's something
that I want to look at,
I will click on the ad.
And as soon as I click
on it, you get paid.
AdMob has unmatched
reach and scale.
That means not only
do we support Android,
but we also support
iOS and Windows.
Also, advertisers
from across the globe
have access to your application.
So, if an advertiser sitting
in the US, UK, Australia
thinks your app is
interesting or if it's
popular in their
country, they can
choose to target your
mobile application,
and you can make a
lot of money with it.
So you can start making
money from AdMob right away.
All you have to do is
sign up for an account,
download and integrate the SDK,
and it's as simple as that.
I hope this session was
helpful, and let's see
you start making money
from AdMob right away.
Thank you.